Just curious to treat my congestion, I put VIX, why that brings back memories.
My mom used VIX on everything, right?
I was told, you're all for everything, it was a VIX.
I used VIX for my, for my, to inhale with steam, I wonder if that was kind of stupid because
all the extra ingredients, what's VIX besides the men fall on campus and you flip this.
I would say it's stupid, yeah, there's petroleum in there, there's turpentine, there's,
you know, there's different stuff in there that's probably not the best for us.
There is a natural VIX on the market, it's not called VIX, but it's called, it's a natural
ointment that doesn't have those things in it that we've used on our kids, and you can
use probably a better thing is just to use essential oils.
You can use essential oils and this is a men fall, that is a good, a better thing to use.